au 42e jour de guerre l'otan se réunit
une nouvelle fois le ministre ukrainien
des affaires étrangères a fait le
déplacement jusqu'à bruxelles à son
arrivée il a demandé trois choses aux
alliés des armes des armes et des armes
pour se défendre
c'est le message que j'adresse aux
alliés il est très simple et j'appelle
tous les alliés à mettre de côté leurs
hésitations leurs réticences pour
fournir à l'ukraine tout ce dont elle a
besoin
car aussi bizarre que cela puisse
paraître aujourd'hui les armes servent à
la paix
les pays qui disent qu'ils fourniront à
l'ukraine des armes défensives mais qui
ne sont pas en mesure de fournir des
armes offensives ils sont hypocrites
s'est approché tout simplement injuste
et injustifiée